المترجم: Haya Al-Hady
المدقّق: Hanan Ben Nafa
مرحبا بكم جميعا
كان هناك أديب و روائي فرنسي
يدعي هنري دوبالزاك
كان له مقولة شهيرة جداً
و هي "وراء كل ثروة جريمة"
اليوم سأشرح لم قال هنري هذه المقولة
و لم ربط الثروة بالجريمة؟
دعوني أسألكم
ما هو أول شيء يخطر في بالكم
عندما تسمعون كلمة جريمة ؟
سجن
مشكلة كبيرة
سرقة
اذا أول ما نفكر فيه هو
السجن و المشاكل الكبيرة
اذا فان تعريف الجريمة في ذهننا
متلخص في تلك الكلمات التي قلتموها الآن
هيا لنقرأ التعريف القانوني للجريمة
كي نعتبر أي فعل جريمة
يجب أن تتوافر ثلاثة شروط
أول شرط أن يتم انتهاك القوانين
ثاني شرط أن يتأذي فرد
من المجتمع أو المجتمع بوجه عام
ما يؤدي الى ثالث عامل
و هو العقوبة
سواء سجن أو حبس أو غرامة
بعد أن عرفنا التعريف القانوني للجريمة
سنقوم الاّن بتشخيص الجريمة
و هي تجربة نفسية
تتطلب استخدام الخيال بشكل كبير
سأطلب من المقدّم كريم أن يأتي و يساعدني
سأسأله بعض الأسئلة
و من خلال إجاباته سأعرف تشخيصه عن الجريمة
كريم
أريد منك أن تتخيل أن الجريمة شخص
مثلي ومثلك، يقف بجانبي الآن على المسرح
هل تعتقد أنه ولد أم بنت ؟
ولد أو رجل كبير
كم عمره ؟
خمس و خمسون
ماذا يرتدي ؟
يرتدي سروال قصير أخضر ممزق
وبه جيوب جانبية
و يرتدي قيمص أخضر بنفس لون القميص
لا اعرف لماذا
و قميص أبيض داخلي بياقة واحدة
هل تعتقد أنه متعلم ؟
لا أعتقد أنه متعلم
هل أنت مرتاح لفكرة أنه يقف بجانبي الآن ؟
لا
هل تشعر أنه يمكن أن أذيني ؟
و يأذيني أنا أيضا
شكرا جزيلاً لك كريم
هذه هي الصورة التي وصفها كريم
أو الشكل المتعارف عليه للمجرم
ما سأتحدث عنه اليوم هو عكس ما ترونه الاّن
لست مهتمة بهذا النوع من المجرمين
لأن شكله واضح و معروف
و إذا رأيته في الشارع
يمكنني أن أفترض أنه مجرم
و لكن أنا مهتمة بهذا النوع من المجرمين
كما ترون
إنه وسيم
ذكي
واضح أنه متعلم
و يمكن أن يكون حاصل علي شهادة
الماجستير أو حتى الدكتوراه
و كما يقال أنه ابن عائلة محترمة
وبتقاضى مرتب جيد في عمله
و لكنه من مجرمي الياقة البيضاء
فما معني مجرمو الياقة البيضاء أو
جرائم الياقة البيضاء ؟
إنه نوع من الجرائم مختلف عن
الجريمة التقليدية التي اعتدنا السماع عنها
كلنا نعرف عن جرائم السرقة و القتل
و السب و القذف و الاعتداء و هكذا
و لكن هذا النوع من الجرائم يكون مختلف جدا
مثل الاختلاس و الرشوة و غسل الأموال
و لكن لم تسمى جرائم الياقة البيضاء
أو مجرمي الياقة البيضاء ؟
لأنه وببساطة، معظم من يرتبكون هذا النوع من الجرائم
يكونون موظفين في القطاع العام أو الخاص
أو رجال أعمال
و أكثر ما يميزهم في مجال عملهم
هو القميص ذو الياقة البيضاء
الذي يرتدونه تحت البدلة
و من هنا جاءت هذه التسمية
كي أبسط الأمور أكثر
يمكننا القول بأن جرائم الياقة البيضاء
هي جرائم غير عنيفة
وتُرتكب من قبل أشخاص علي مستوى
اجتماعي عالي.. أناس مثلنا من عائلات محترمة
و يستغلوا خبراتهم و ذكائهم في مجال عملهم
كي يرتبكوا هذا النوع من الجرائم
كما قلت سابقا
من أنواع جرائم الياقة البيضاء
الاختلاس و الرشوة و غسل الأموال
و لكن اليوم سأناقش أكثر نوعين
سيثيروا اهتمامكم
أول نوع هو المقايضات الداخلية
و ثاني نوع هو مخطط بونزي
ما هي المقايضات الداخلية ؟
تعتبر المقايضات الداخلية انتهاك للثقة
و هذا النوع من الجرائم
يُرتكب عادةً في البورصة
أعتقد أن الجميع قد شاهد فيلم
ذئب شارع وال wolf of wall street
عندما كان النجم ليوناردو ديكابريو
كان يقوم بتسريب معلومات سرية
لعملائه مقابل المال
و هذا النوع من المقايضات يدعي
المقايضات الداخلية
هذه هي صورة جوردن بلفورد
أو الشخص الحقيقي التي كانت
قصة الفيلم مستوحاة من شخصه
كما ترون هو وسيم
ذكي
وحاصل على دكتوراه، على فكرة
و المضحك في الموضوع أنه متحدث تشجيعي
لقد حُكم عليه بالسجن أربعة أعوام
و دفع مئة و عشر ملايين دولار مقابل
جرائم المقايضات الدخلية التي كان يقوم بها
ثاني نوع من جرائم الياقة البيضاء
يطلق عليه مخطط بونزي
أو المخطط الهرمي
سُمي هذا المخطط نسبةً لرجل أعمال إيطالي
يدعُي تشارلز بونزي
و هو أول من ابتدع هذا النوع من الجرائم
فما هو المخطط الهرمي إذاً ؟
يعني ببساطة
"اسرق من بيتر لتعطي أو تدفع لبول"
فأذهب إلى شباب مثلكم
يسعون وراء الربح السريع
و أقول لهم أنني سأستثمر هذه الأموال
اّخذ منهم المال
ولكن أعيد إليكم جزءاً بسيطاً من الربح
ليس لأنني استثمرت المال
و لكن لأنني أخذت هذا المال
من مستثمرين جدد
وأشهر مثال لهذا هنا في مصر
كان شبكة كيو "كيو-نت"
الاّن بعد أن عرفنا تعريف
جرائم الياقة البيضاء و أنواعها
أنا واثقة أنكم تتساءلون
لماذا يقوم المجرم ذا الياقة البيضاء
شخص متعلم
ابن عائلة محترمة ويتقاضى مرتب جيد
لم هو مجرم؟
مالذي يحتاج إليه بينما لديه كل شيء؟
بالنسبة للمجرم الذي وصفه كريم منذ قليل
تكون دوافعه و مبرراته واضحة
مثل: الجوع و الفقر و الجهل وغيرهم
و لكن ما هي مبررات مرتكبي
جرائم الياقة البيضاء ؟
علماء الجريمة
منذ 1920
كرسوا حياتهم حتي يعرفوا أسباب ارتكاب
جرائم الياقة البيضاء
و كونوا نظريات كثيرة
و اليوم سأخبركم عن أهم ثلاث نظريات
أول نظرية هي نظرية الميزات
و تنقسم الي جزئين
جزء نفسي
و جزء حيوي
الجزء النفسي
يقول أنه هناك سبع صفات
إذا تواجدوا عند شخص ما
اذا فهناك احتمال كبير أنه احدي مرتكبي
جرائم الياقة البيضاء
فما هي السبع صفات ؟
يخاف الخسارة والفشل تحت أي ظروف
شخص متحكم
شخص أناني لا يحب إلا نفسه
شخص مسيطر
بدون أدني وعي اتجاه المجتمع الذي يعيش فيه
غير نزيه
و يكون شخص ملفت للاهتمام جدا (كارزمي)
اذا اجتمعت هذه الصفات في شخص
يزيد احتمال أن يكون من
مرتكبي جرائم الياقة البيضاء
الجزء الثاني من هذه النظرية
هو الجزء الحيوي
حيث أن الجينات الوراثية
هي العامل الأساسي في تكوين المجرم
و قد بُني هذا الاستنتاج علي أساس
نظرية ابتدعها عالم إيطالي
اسمه سيزر لمبروزو
و كان يعتقد أن المجرم يولد
ولديه جينات إجرامية
توارثها من فرد من أفراد عائلته
وهذا ما يجعله مجرما
أي أن المجرم يولد كمجرم
و لكن بدون مشاكل نفسية
ثاني نظرية هي نظرية السلالة العامة
و هي منتشرة هنا في مصر
طبعا عندما نتخرج جميعا من الكلية
نكون متوترين و نريد أن نثبت وجودنا سريعا
و البعض يكونوا ذوي إرادة ضعيفة
فيضطروا الي أن يسلكوا طرق ملتوية
ليصلوا الى أهدافهم في عملهم
والنظرية ترى بأن المبررات
هنا تكون واضحة جداً
الأشخاص يكونوا ذوي إرادة
ضعيفة فيسلكون أساليب غير قانونية
ثالث نظرية والتي مقتنعة بها أنا جداً
هي نظرية الاختيار العقلاني
أقتنع بهذه النظرية لأنها جزء
من رسالتي للدكتوراه
تنفي هذه النظرية وجود أي مشاكل نفسية أو حيوية
أو ضغوط عملية تساهم في ارتكاب هذه الجرائم
إذا ما هي مشكلة هذا المجرم ؟
يكون مرتكب جرائم الياقة البيضاء
شخص ذكي جدا
و يخطط جيدا لما يفعل
فيقوم بعملية حسابية
اسمها الفوائد ضد التكلفة
ما هي الفائدة ؟
هي العائد المادي من الجريمة
أما الثمن
هل سيتم إلقاء القبض عليه ؟
هل سيدفع غرامة ؟ و كم ستكون ؟
يقوم المجرم بهذه العملية الحسابية
ويخرج باستنتاج
إذا كانت الفوائد أكبر من التكلفة
يرتكب الجريمة
أما اذا كانت التكلفة أكثر من الفائدة
فلا يرتكب الجريمة أبداً
و لهذا تُسمي نظرية الاختيار العقلاني
مصر تحتل المركز الرابع والتسعين
بين مئة و خمس و سبعين دولة في الفساد
وفقا لمؤشر مكافحة الفساد لعام 2014
و هو مركز عالي
فكلما يزيد الرقم
يزيد مستوى الفساد
ويزيد مستوى الخطر
إذا سألتكم لماذا تحتل مصرهذا المركز
العالي في الفساد
يمكن أن تجيبوني بأن السبب هو: الحكومة
بسبب المنظومة التعليمية
بسبب الفقر والجهل
و لكن ما لا تعلموه
أن سبب انتشار الفساد إلى هذا الحد في مصر
هو جرائم الياقة البيضاء
و لكن ما سبب انتشار جرائم الياقة البيضاء ؟
إنه سؤال بسيط
و إجابته بسيطة
السبب هو القانون
للأسف لدينا أربع مشاكل
في القانون المصري
الذي يكافح جرائم الياقة البيضاء
أول مشكلة
أنه هناك قوانين مُصاغة جيدا
و لكن لا يُطبق
فيرتكب المجرم جرائم الياقة البيضاء
و هو يعلم أن القانون لن يُفعّل ضده
ثاني مشكلة
هي القوانين التي تمت صياغتها منذ وقت طويل
منذ الثمانينات أو الستينات
و هذه القوانين لا تواكب الجديد
في عالم الأعمال اليوم
فيقوم المجرم بالجريمة بطرق معاصرة و حديثة
و هو يعرف أن أساليبه
غير منصوص عليها في القوانين
ثالث مشكلة والأكثر الخطورة
هي عدم وجود قوانين من الأساس
حتي الاّن
ليس لدينا قانون لمكافحة جرائم الانترنت
رابع مشكلة
أنه لدينا قوانين جيدة ومُصاغة جيداً
و لكن بدون عقوبات رادعة
يمكن أن ترهب مرتكب جرائم الياقة البيضاء
فعندما يري المجرم أن العقوبة تكون
مجرد دفع مبلغاً من المال
فهو لن يهتم لهذه الغرامة
مقارنة بما يربحه من جريمته
بعد أن ناقشنا المشكلة
نعاني من معدل كبير من
جرائم الياقة البيضاء
ما يؤدي إلى الفساد
فما هي الحلول ؟
سأطرح أربع حلول
لمكافحة جرائم الياقة البيضاء
أول حل
هو تعديل و تحسين
القوانين المصرية الخاصة بجرائم الفساد
فيجب أن يجتمع رجال القانون من: المشرعين
والقضاة ووكلاء النيابة
و يبحثوا عن القوانين التي نعاني
من نقص فيها
و يعدلوا القوانين
و يصيغوا قوانين جديدة للجرائم الجديدة
ثاني حل هو اللجوء لـ
و لاستفادة من علماء الجريمة
فعلماء الجريمة هم من يكرسون حياتهم
كي يكتشفوا أسباب و دوافع
مرتكبي جرائم الياقة البيضاء
علماء الجريمة في مصر
يستطيعوا أن يقدموا تقارير للحكومة
تتضمن أسباب جرائم الياقة البيضاء في مصر
ربما هي أسباب اجتماعية
أو نفسية
أو بسبب القوانين الحالية
أية اسباب
ولكن ستعمل هذه التقارير على
زيادة الوعي لدى الحكومة
و يستطيعون أن يستنتجوا
النقص الموجود حاليا في القوانين
فتبدأ في تحسينها لمنع
جرائم الياقة البيضاء
ثالث حل
هو إنشاء مركز لمكافحة
جرائم الياقة البيضاء
و هو موجود في أمريكا
و نحن بحاجة لإنشاء هذا المركز في مصر
سيهتم هذا المركز بمراقبة و فحص الشركات
و الصفقات التي تحدث بين رجال
الأعمال أوالشركات الوطنية والدولية
فالمجرم ذا الياقة البيضاء
حينما يبحث عن تنفيذ جريمة
سيعرف إحتمالية كشف جريمته
لدينا في مصر مركزين يشبهان
مركز مكافحة جرائم الياقة البيضاء
جهاز حماية المنافسة
و جهاز الرقابة الادارية
و لكن مع احترامي
انهم لا يملكون الاّليات أو المعرفة
أو الخبرة الكافية
ليكافحوا هذا النوع من الجرائم
وهذا ليس تقليلا من شأنهم،
بل لأن هذا النوع من الجرائم
محدد و حساس
و يرتكبه مجرمون أذكياء
و لهذا نحتاج الى خبراء في هذا المجال
رابع حل
هو زيادة الوعي العام
في مصر نحن لا نعرف شيئا عن
جرائم الياقة البيضاء
لهذا فإننا في أشد الحاجة
لحملات توعية لرجال القانون والمواطنين
عن مدى خطورة جرائم الياقة البيضاء
لأن بارتفاع التوعية
ستقل الجريمة
وانطلاقاٌ من تجربتي أيضاً، عندما أحقق
مع موظفين في الشركة
دائما لديهم مخرج معروف
أنهم لا يعرفون أن ما فعلوه ضد القانون
مثل الدردشة مع صديق عن صفقة مالية
و لكن القانون لا يحمي المغفلين
الاّن نعلم جميعا المغزى من
ربط هنري دوبالزاك
الثروة بالجريمة
و أريدكم جميعا أن تتذكروا
أن اليوم في الجريمة
الأبيض هو الأسود الجديد
شكرا جزيلا لكم